I think I think the this profession is
going probably you're probably you have
the great advantage that there are other
professions that have gone through this
before you and you can see what they've
done and right and wrong and you can see
other industries as well how they've
screwed it up so for example and it's
because because they waited for the
change to happen as opposed to grabbing
the bulls by the horn the bull by the
horns right one ass no big deal right
and so for example why is it that
Netflix invented Netflix and not the
movie and television industry it's
because the moving television industry
were protecting their old business model
and literally ignorant of the fact that
the world was changing around them you
know the Netflix had this new
subscription model and it was a small
company blockbuster which was the
800-pound gorilla like you remember when
we used to get DVDs in the mail so like
they knew streaming was coming they just
didn't it was just wasn't very yet and
so the CEO of Blockbuster went to the
board and said I think we should explore
subscription because this little thing
called Netflix is onto something that's
gonna happen when when the technology
gets better and the board wouldn't let
him change the business model to
subscription because they made 12
percent of their revenues from late fees
and look what happened
Blockbuster does not exist except for
one store in northern Canada
and and Netflix is the is the dominant
force in television movies why is it
that a computer company invented iTunes
and not the music industry is because
they saw the change coming and the the
music industry was still trying to
protect selling albums and stores
because they saw their customer as Tower
Records and HMV whereas iTunes Apple so
the customers the person who actually
buys and listens to the music why is it
that Amazon invented Amazon and the EU
leader and publishing industry did not
even invent the Kindle like that is it's
because they're too busy protecting the
old business model so I think if you if
you go down this route of protectionism
of protecting what we have and staving
off change you are signing your own
death warrant and if it's not your death
warrant your business is gonna become
way more difficult and another firm or
another that may be completely outside
your profession remember iTunes Netflix
all of these were companies completely
outside their own industry in other
words they couldn't even figure out
which one of you it's gonna be because
it won't be any of you it might be a
software company that'll completely
eviscerate your your profession and and
so I think to be to be the the one that
says okay it won't be the way it was we
can't defend the way it was and we're
gonna have to imagine what if we would
invent our industry now knowing nothing
what would we do and again this goes
back to the question of why well why did
you get into the industry in the first
place did you get into this profession
because you because your parents told
you to and you can make a good living
you're not gonna be the innovator you
know did you get in this industry
because you love math you know you're
not gonna be the innovator did you get
into this industry and do you love this
industry when you really get to help
people re understand and reimagine how
to build an organization because when
you can understand the language of
mathematics we're gonna send the
language of a balance sheet as clearly
as you can understand the language of
cultural change that's it's kind of like
that right it's it's it's the rational
and the emotional
it's and we said it before which is the
numbers are only half a picture of the
health of the business and and if you
got in this industry to be of service to
human beings who are trying to do bigger
things for for themselves for their
families for society through their
customers you might be onto something so
the question is what serve what value do
you offer to the people who buy your
product now how would you do that in
this new changing day and age and
literally ignore whatever was because
it's irrelevant because it may or may
not survive the industry the the profit
that the profession will do fine if if
you're if you're the ones willing to
blow up your own business but if if you
if you're going to protect your business
it'll get blown up for you
[Music]